i know
i know
what about you where are you from i'm
from moscow originally i spent a lot of
time living sort of in the states and in
the uk
i mean i've got friends in ukraine i've
got friends in mariopol who don't have
connection to their family
i've got friends in kiev i've got
friends who managed to get out all of us
have friends or have been to ukraine or
you know have family there it's it's
such a mixed culture that
i mean as in like it's you know it's
like england attacking scotland it just
doesn't happen
hey
hello
how are you
i am very
bad however i know i'm better than you
at the moment
because it is
happening in your country because of my
country
and
nothing is worse than a war
there's a
almost no words to describe there are no
words what is happening
in this world right now
but it gives me hope to see that
we are all opposed to war
yeah
no matter our heritage
no matter
what was friends
it's the war of putin
one power hungry
madman that wants to restore
something that shouldn't exist in a
modern world
we're from
i'm from ukraine obviously um i'm from
the western part
i'm from the part that's
always been um
very
ukrainian and very
pro-west
these days it's also the part that's the
safest and where a lot of people seek
refuge where are you from
i'm from moscow
also from
the part of russia and from the
community which has not been a huge
supporter
while practically never being a
supporter
of the current government and
particularly what's happening now
hi hello how are you
hard to consider here with the minus of
everything that's happening uh i'm tanya
uh
is your family safe
uh yesterday they fled flat from kiev
they were evacuated on the train
free trains and obviously they're very
crowded and like on the railway station
it's a kind of revolution yeah really
difficult to get out but yeah they
managed and now they're
in western western part of you that's
good
so yeah it was first night them outside
home and yeah first night without
bombing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and actually it was the first night
when i slept a bit better yeah i can
imagine
first days of this
thing
i was just crying
then i got
very strong desire for suicide
you you can't
sleep
you don't wanna eat
you can't
work
you can't think of
anything but this
thinking about how i will tell about
these days
to my children
because
i don't want to be in this presence
i feel
and i have felt
almost every day like i'm in fight or
flight mode
i have this adrenaline that is
i'm channeling into action
and huge fear for my friends and family
that
remain because
putin cannot be reasoned with
and he's only showed that
when he's backed into a corner he hits
harder
what's been the worst moment in the last
two weeks
for myself it was um when my mum called
me at 5 am so i knew something is wrong
and she just she was just crying and she
said they're bombing us they're bombing
us we're running i'm like where are you
running
she said well we're just going to this
different house to the basement we're
grabbing the baby now and it's and i i
was just i was shaking i didn't know
what to do i
it was
absolutely devastating you don't you
don't know where to put yourself you
you can't help them all you can do is
just try and call them but you also feel
almost bad because you don't know maybe
they're running maybe they're doing
something maybe they're holding
something they can't answer your phone
and if they don't answer
the stress you start feeling and
it's it's unexplainable unless someone
has lived through it it's it's it's it's
the worst thing ever
the worst moment was was to find this
news that it's actually started like i
screamed
it was at night yeah i started to read
news and screamed and cried and i'm very
worried that my aunt she's
now in her house near to kiev and she's
not in touch anymore i know that there
are russian armies coming close to that
particular area and
there is no connection with her and we
don't know what's happening so it just
one member of my family just disappeared
now and so i just i hope that she's all
right there but we don't know yeah
what's happening
i cried terribly when i found out
because i woke up and i saw
the messages from my friends in
ukraine
but i think the worst happened on sixth
day when it was understood that it's
gonna continue and then i started crying
and i couldn't stop for two hours i feel
torn from my own family i don't think my
son
will be able to see great parents
for a while
it's a small thing
your parents are in russia now in peru
i don't think and do they support all
this or part of them so
just obvious to me
i don't understand why it's not obvious
to them
and i can't be silent about this because
my friends are there
so i'm vocal in every social media
channel
call it the war the war
which means i can't come back unless i
won 15 years of colony in my own country
so i will never come back
until it's over
the very first text from my dad where
he he said
oh my god
we kind of have a war starting here and
uh no panic
love you a lot and when i called him he
said that he's not leaving under any
circumstances because
he has people take care of and that was
the scariest part because then like i
want to see my dad
i just want to see him and i don't know
when
i'm so sorry i just i can't believe you
yeah it is not but um
i'm still very sorry
what's been the worst moment for you
tina
the worst moment it's like this
one
big moment but actually
this thing worries me as well that i i
don't know
if and when uh
i'll be able to go home and
see my family my family is physically
safe and all of this
but it feels
awful it feels really bad i don't know
how else to describe this it is really
painful and i guess like of the first
day you kind of try to just like okay
what can i do and like how i can get on
with my life and try to help like as
much as possible you kind of want to
think
about like who you put on risk if you do
something at the same time you kind of
don't want to think about this because
that's the kind of thinking that they
want and that's how they win
but all of this is like a continuous
like one
horrible moment i would say
tina you said there that
you're worried it can be a worry for
people talking about because they might
put people at risk back in russia
um yeah
but you're still here today and you're
still talking about this right now why
did you decide why did you decide to
come today well i agreed before they
passed the law
but um
i have russian friends who like
risk so much more and i can see russian
people talking and they literally risk
their whole career their families like
everything and they still speak up and
i'm like
i mean i'm sorry like i literally
there's nothing for me to
not much for me to
be scared of although we'll see right
you never know so
i had a couple of russian friends from
like years ago reach out
on the first day and they were like yeah
we're gonna like we're so supportive
we're gonna go out and then two three
days after and they're just quiet and i
know it's scary to go to these places
because you can just be put in in like a
truck and taken away to prison but
it's much scarier to be in a bomb
shelter and there are a lot of russians
in london that i know personally
that just kind of post these
like black squares was no war
and it's it and it just puts me in this
situation of like despair and like it
gets exhausting just trying to say
something to people while also checking
all the news and being scared to like
open your phone because what if it's
like
your relatives who didn't
survive and this is it's not a personal
attack of course it's just like
the thoughts that i've been having
it's very disheartening to see that
people are not doing enough in russia
it's like you have to stand for this
but you don't why don't you
to explain all of this is just the
feeling that that you have like there is
nothing can be done in russia this
feeling was cultivated for like decades
the propaganda the brainwashing it was a
gradual
demolishing
of the whole
landscape people were living politicians
were arrested some
were killed and you're like well those
big people they they tried and they
failed so now
i will probably try
and most likely i will fail
and it's not going to help
and i will just lose my life
there's so much poison especially in the
rural areas that have listened to
putin's propaganda for
over 20 years when he's been in control
even those with
relatives in ukraine don't believe that
this war is happening
how do we bring truth
when there has been such systematic
indoctrination
last night there were some hackers who
hacked russian tv
isn't that cool
yeah it's very cool
yesterday a couple of my friends were
detained in petersburg and in moscow for
going on the protests
and 10 000 people were detained yeah
and they had like a special female
column
like a pro-feministic movement was also
going outside in the streets and they
were a couple of them were tortured in
the police station
but unfortunately it's not a big number
uh i wish i could say the majority of
russians don't support that but i don't
feel that it's unfortunate because the
choice they're making is to be oblivious
is because in order to say
putin is a crime criminal
it's taking you out of your comfort zone
and that means that you are in a country
of aggression that means you you are the
one who is responsible
it's sad because in a way
you're you're standing on the side of
the truth and the light
you're protecting what is really dear
it's your home
while uh
russians and my friends who are sharing
exactly the same views as i am just feel
that we don't hope home anymore like we
can't come home
we don't have home
and some of our relatives are not even
what kind of food yes in our homes like
my home was key and my home was saint
petersburg i lost
both you think a revolution will happen
i
can't
assume that it will not because
otherwise there will be
no life
for
everybody who i have in russia
and this revolution there will be at
least a chance
that gives me hope
you're currently sat opposite someone
who's on the other side of this conflict
i'm not on the other side of this
conflict let me rephrase that
currently
opposite someone is a ukrainian officer
someone is a russian here
is there anything you would like to say
to each other
you'll stop him
i love that
oh god i i want
if only every russian person could say
that this would be done because you
can't imprison a whole country
i think speaking to you has really given
me hope that
the resistance is growing and that a
revolution is possible to overthrow
our
our version of hitler in 2022.
there is no choice
if you have relatives in russia
or any friends acquaintances anyone
and if you have any
people in russia brainwashed or not just
speak to them as much as possible that's
the
the only the only thing you can possibly
do as well
that's all i have to say sure
i am doing this i will do my best um
what i would like to say to you
i mean
i just wish i just hope your
family's safe and it's all happens as
soon as possible and
you keep strong
is there anything that you haven't had
the chance to say that you want to say
if we fail you're next if people in the
west don't say something don't try to do
something and they don't try to stop
this the person who's behind all this
war
will come for europe
what does that mean
no war
i believe ukraine will win
well my country is strong and we protect
our home yes life of all ukrainians
and truth is on our side yes
thank you
um
hi my name is elena i'm a pr manager
from ukraine
hi my name is ann and i'm a photographer
from ukraine